first our count continues sadly
americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day 110.
i know the media's turned the page joe
biden's turn the page we will never turn
the page it's 110 days since joe biden
abandoned americans in afghanistan
military families green card holders our
afghan allies it's 123 days since he
promised he'd leave nobody behind joe
biden lied to every american joe you can
still go rescue the americans the green
card holders the military families that
you abandoned the ones you promised you
wouldn't abandon
back home joe was barely able to form a
cogent sentence today during what can be
only described as another rambling
bumbling mumbling speech about covet 19.
the very frail-looking joe biden
struggled to speak at all and seemingly
coughing up an entire lung in the
process take a look
without cutting corners on for safety to
get such vaccines renewed reviewed and
renewed
reviewed and approved if they're needed
and then get your booster shot when
you're when you're eligible
oh
excuse me
we don't yet believe
that additional measures will be needed
i was just told it's a question i got to
ask i've been meaning to ask for a long
time
whether or not not just it increases the
the
the resistance to the variant that is
being dealt with
but it also is
it it is stronger
it not only just raises the total but
it's a stronger it makes things more
powerful in terms of resisting
this is not funny
that's supposed to be the leader of the
free world he's clearly not well
yesterday during another concerning
moment joe biden flat out lied about an
important trip to israel during the six
day war one problem we'll tell you about
but first watch this
i was saying to a couple of younger
members of my staff before i came over
but the many times i've been to israel i
said not all of a sudden i realized god
you're getting nobody
i have known every
every prime minister well
since golda meir including gold in my
ear
and
during the six-day war i had an
opportunity to uh
she invited me to come over because i
was going to be the liaison between she
and the egyptians about the suez and so
on and so forth
one big problem
none of that happened joe wasn't there
he wasn't even in the senate instead at
the time he was getting really bad
grades in law school but don't worry in
between the lies the bumbling mumbling
confusion and weakness joe biden has
covet 19 he's got it all figured out
earlier today announcing that the
federal mass mandate on trains planes
will be extended to the spring of 2022
also encouraging every american to wear
a mask at all times indoors before
sauntering off stage
mask free take a look
and we are extending the requirement
both internationally and domestically to
wear masks for travel on aircraft
trains public transportation
through the winter months thank you for
your patience and listening to me thank
you
[Applause]
and then make to make matters worse joe
is now reportedly considering a vaccine
mandate for domestic travel but still
preferential treatment exists for
illegal immigrants that continues no
kova testing no vaccine mandates and yes
free travel courtesy of you the taxpayer
to the state of their choice where
illegal immigrants will receive free
room and board and shelter and health
care and free education this as biden's
current vaccine mandates are getting
held up in court but joe doesn't care he
does whatever the flip-flopping dr fauci
tells them to do he follows him blindly
it's almost as if an unelected dishonest
lifelong bureaucrat is now running the
country it's that bad take a look
continuing to give me advice on
developments as they occur
i've seen more
of dr fauci that i have my wife we kid
each other but
they look who's president fauci
but all kidding aside i sincerely mean
it
this is not good for our country dr
fauci should not have any role in our
federal government he needs to be fired
needed to be fired a long time ago he
also needs to be investigated for lying
to congress found she got literally
every single solitary thing on covid
wrong everything from the beginning
february 2020 he said the risk of coven
19 in the u.s is minuscule yeah he was
wrong a few weeks later he encouraged
americans to travel on cruise ships
saying no reason not to go once again
dead wrong after nearly all of his
models projections they were all wrong
and remember two weeks to slow the
spread he was wrong again and let's not
forget about his ever-evolving positions
on masks first it was ugh mass don't
work you know maybe maybe stop a little
bit but it doesn't work and it was one
mass then it was two masks then it was
masked indoors not outdoors then it was
vax or mast and it was vax and mass now
it's vax mask uh and booster and
probably ten more boosters after that
now first no vaccine mandate now we
support mandates no one on earth has
been more inconsistent on covet 19 than
america's so-called top expert anthony
flip-flop fauci and it gets worse fauci
also misled everyone in the country on
the origins of culver 19. maybe that's
because under his direction it was his
nih that was funding the dangerous gain
of function research at that wuhan
institute of virology prior to the
outbreak in fact on october the 20th his
own nih admitted that they funded a
study at the wuhan lab where quote spike
proteins were tested from naturally
occurring bat coronavirus coronaviruses
circulating in china to see if they were
capable of binding to a human being that
is by its very definition gain of
function research you paid for it but on
may 11th fauci testified the nih was not
ever involved in funding gain of
function research at the wuhan institute
of virology not ever not at all dr fauci
is a liar now who knows whether or not
anthony fauci will ever get prosecuted
that only seems to happen to
conservatives or people that know donald
trump let alone even investigated for
lying to congress don't hold your breath
but make no mistake anthony fauci has to
go he needs to be fired today he is
dishonest incompetent and he speculates
widely and he's wrong often and he
spends more time as a political pundit
on tv than an actual doctor and more
than anything he seems to love the
limelight according to the conspiracy
theorists at msdnc half the country no
longer trusts dr fauci because they want
the pandemic to continue
what
name one person that wants this adam
shift show to continue
take a look
if people follow fauchi there's likely a
chance that covet will go away and if
coba goes away it's bad right now for
republicans it's just the math on this
the political math and this is not hard
to figure out yeah
heilemann is just a completely unhinged
idiot
even for the network that features you
know the tinfoil hat wearing rachel
maddow who's going to get 30 million
dollars according to reports for one
show a week and democratic operative
chucky todd he'll never be tim russert
but let me be clear i would not wish
covet on my worst enemy i want everybody
whether you agree with me politically or
not if you're a liberal democrat if
you're part of the progressive caucus uh
you hate me you want me off the air
please be careful i want you to live
make no mistake every conservative that
i know wants life to return to normal no
more lockdowns no more draconian
measures no mandates no masks no
lectures no scolding we're sick of it
now here's a news flash for msdnc
americans don't like anthony fauci
because he's horrible at his job and
he's wrong constantly and the bar
changes every hour of every day if biden
really cared about reaching all
americans he would replace fauci with
someone less toxic that appears not to
be happening joe biden is not a uniter
he's a cognitively struggling mess of a
democratic socialist marxist from
delaware who is in way over his head and
everybody knows it so now he does
whatever his far left advisors tell him
to do hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else